[Musique]
les meilleures notes
une des meilleures de votre promotion
mais surtout à cause du grand sacrifice
que vous avez fait pour votre pays c'est
de la littérature séditieuse c'est un
crime et c'est anti national nous aider
à arrêter votre père a été un grand
exemple de courage tous les civils et
pour les officiers merci monsieur je
veux ajouter le tout dernier aveu
ce délit saidalya coupe ton nom et ton
âge tu on en parle
ils répètent la même phrase en boucle
quelque chose au sujet d'un devoir
accompli voilà la main dévoiler leur
culpabilité et se repaître de leur chair
comment attendu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]